i want to start today with something
that's kind of
really good news
uh some in the audience have grown
increasingly frustrated with me
that i have not
really
put out my sense of a way to
radically
deprogram right-wing extremists and
reactionaries from
uh fact-free trumpism or ignorant
political ideas call it what you will
but the question that we've been kind of
grappling with is
okay great tens of millions of people
think trump actually won they would vote
for him again they believe
untrue things about vaccines and climate
change and the pandemic and all these
different things great we've identified
a problem how do we fix it and at the
individual level we know well you know
if you spend three hours six hours with
individuals you can change some minds
but that's a really difficult thing to
do at a sort of large scale
at the same time when we think about
something from above that radically and
quickly changes views uh we're often
talking about significant
authoritarianism which is a progressive
i am against authoritarianism so we
don't really have an answer but we we
now have a new study
that is
really inspiring and reassuring that it
is possible although what we can
actually do as a result remains a
question mark so i'm talking about um a
a incredible new study called the
manifold effects of partisan media on
viewers beliefs and attitudes a field
experiment with fox news viewers and
there's a good write-up of what this did
and essentially what they did is they
took fox news viewers and they paid them
they paid them
to watch cnn for 30 days and what they
found was that after watching cnn for 30
days
the fox news viewers became more
skeptical about fake actual fake news
less likely to buy into fake news
and they also found changes in attitudes
and policy preferences on covet 19
on evaluations of then president trump
and of republican candidates and they
wrote and this is so
not incredible but but it's a good thing
despite regular fox news viewers being
largely strong partisans we found
manifold effects of changing the slant
of their media diets on their factual
beliefs
attitudes
perceptions of issues importance and
overall political views
they write it found that fox news gave
viewers information about why the
disease is not a serious threat while
cnn provided more information about the
disease itself this changed people's
views and it goes on and it says a lot
more about what was done here and this
is important for so many different
reasons now obviously
if you think cnn is bad and not
trustworthy on the facts then you would
see this as bad you would say wow
they believe the right things when they
watch fox news
and after 30 days of watching cnn all of
a sudden they believe all these liberal
lies now on these particular issues we
know during the pandemic when trump was
president fox news was giving a very
skewed perspective of the pandemic and
about other issues so you can argue as
to whether it's a good thing or not that
they end up believing what they see on
cnn rather than what they see on fox but
that's not the issue i want to focus in
on
the incredible good news is
if we put the right information in front
of people we can debate what the right
information is but if we put the right
information if we put accurate
information in front of people
their beliefs
are not as resistant to revision
as we might have thought
and
the other kind of scary aspect of this
is it reminds us of the significant
impact of one's media diet
it's incredible or maybe not maybe we
say it's disturbing
what happens to people's beliefs when
their media diet is restricted to what
we might call extremist media or
disinformation media and to some extent
i will gladly concede that cnn
profits off of
and
depends on
fear-mongering salacious stories the
kind of if it bleeds it leads the most
extremist and hyperbolic interpretation
of things with a different perspective
than fox news but cnn is nowhere near as
dishonest we have to understand the kind
of corporate fear leads framing um
when i was on my flight to las vegas in
fact
there was a guy sitting across the aisle
from me and i it's a long flight from
the east coast five and a half six hours
i watched him consume hours of fox news
but then later in the flight i looked
over and msnbc was on
and
it was interesting because i was reading
the study on the flight as i was
watching this guy
and we might
wrongly say well the msnbc is going to
have no impact on the guy and what the
study shows is that it does now again
msnbc
is a not as
dishonest
editorially liberal corporate media
outlet so for me msnbc is not exactly
the solution to fox news and what this
gets me back to is
many people are kind of addicted to
outrage
fear
anger and validation of their existing
views as well because the anger gives
people sometimes what is like a
temporary relief from what are maybe
more difficult feelings to deal with you
know despair in their lives or a feeling
of helpless helplessness or whatever the
case may be conspiracy content as we've
talked about before is sometimes
soothing to people because they would
rather believe everything is planned and
orchestrated rather than there are
random bad events that we really can't
predict specifically and so my main
takeaway from this study is the great
news is
people's beliefs aren't as resistant to
revision as we thought
if we put the right content in front of
them but the most important takeaway for
me is
i don't really want
the population to simply be a cnn or
msnbc population rather than a fox news
population is it better of course
my preference would be what i try to do
as a media diet which is i'm getting the
bulk of what
i
believe is going on about the world
from news reporting agencies those that
have been shown to be more trustworthy
in a number of different studies and
evaluations associated press
reuters
many other examples from other countries
etc i want that to be the bulk of what
i'm understanding and then after that
i want to fill in with the perspectives
from some of these media outlets i mean
kovid's a great example
i wasn't taking my beliefs about kovid
from cnn norfox nor msnbc nor you know
whoever i'm i my view was let me look at
epidemiologists let me look at health
agencies let me look at interesting
researchers let me look at statistics
people people like nasim talib who would
take the data and say as a statistician
here is my interpretation and then let's
see how fox and cnn and others are
covering it russia ukraine is sort of
another example so
this is a reassuring article
but for me the solution isn't just
sitting people in front of msnbc or cnn
it's teaching them
that
msnbc and cnn should really be like at
the top of the information pyramid more
like the junk food and i include my show
in that as well notice that unlike you
know the reactionary right that says i'm
the only one telling you the truth
i should just be sort of a meeting place
where after we've all hopefully done our
homework we come together to share
opinions so interesting study we'll link
to it i encourage you to check it out
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the united states for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think
it's happened to me i've talked about
this on the show before and it can be
really bad sometimes you get a text that
your email password has been changed
your bank calls about unusual activity
your paypal account is getting drained
and it can happen very very quickly to
keep my accounts protected i use aura
our sponsor aura is identity theft
protection
fraud monitoring and password management
all wrapped into one aura monitors the
dark web for your information they
monitor your credit card they monitor
your bank accounts my subscription to
aura gives me peace of mind uh protects
my devices it protects all of my
different accounts and i can monitor
everything in one place on the app if i
get attacked aura actually takes action
to prevent and resolve the issues in
real time and aura is letting my
audience try it completely free for 14
days go to aura.com
pacman the link is down below